cuando el presidente marrón se ha
dirigido a los franceses a lo largo de
esta pandemia lo ha hecho en momentos
bastante críticos y bastante claves se
tienen tres hipótesis sobre la mesa por
una parte dejar las cosas así como están
con el toque de queda en todo el
territorio y los 19 departamentos que
por ahora están confinados aunque una
manera bocina miento ligero pero
repartir mejor los pacientes en las
unidades de reanimación esto sin el aval
de las familias como viene siendo hasta
ahora la otra hipótesis es el cierre de
escuelas y colegios algo que el gobierno
ha querido evitar y lo ha venido
evitando incluso durante el segundo
confinamiento a finales del año pasado
las escuelas permanecieron abiertas y
por último pues es la decisión más
dolorosa digamos o más difícil que
volvería a ser un confinamiento estricto
así como el que se decretó en la
primavera pasada pero que quizás
solamente se aplicaría a los 19
departamentos donde la situación
actualmente es crítica